[SPEAKER_01]: para Trix obviamente quiero pues primero conversarlo contigo yo sé que tú tienes muy claro pues más o menos o más o menos no tienes muy claro que las necesidades que tienen Trix y lo estás viviendo de primera persona como todos esos problemas que te ha generado de pronto la falta de tecnología no tener pues como herramientas que te faciliten a ti un poco el trabajo y obviamente pues como con tu mamá han vivido el crecimiento y han vivido el desarrollo de la compañía
[SPEAKER_01]: y pues la que tiene pues como un entendimiento de lo que está pasando, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, muy bien.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces te voy a presentar aquí pantalla, esto pues es un trabajo como inicial, esta no es la versión final, aquí digamos que es primero pues como para que tú me digas tu opinión, después ya más adelante si tienes dudas o comentarios o cualquier cosa me interrumpes y lo resolvemos, la idea tampoco es quitarte mucho tiempo, yo tengo disponibilidad.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lo que tú quieras.
[SPEAKER_01]: Está bien.
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Listo?
[SPEAKER_01]: Adelante.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfecto.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, empezamos pues primero viendo qué es lo que nosotros vimos dentro de la reunión que tuvimos de Trix.
[SPEAKER_01]: Esto es como el entendimiento que como compañía, bueno, te presento, nosotros, yo, obviamente tú me conoces a mí, la compañía que estoy montando con mi hermano se llama Nexo Strat, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_01]: Amigo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Todo el análisis, como que toda la información que estamos recopilando de la compañía de ustedes para hacerles la presentación, la hacemos en conjunto entre mi hermano y yo y obviamente utilizamos muchas herramientas de AI como para apoyarnos en todo esto.
[SPEAKER_01]: El entendimiento de Trix hoy, que lo hemos recopilado por medio de la presentación que ustedes, o de la conversación que tuvimos con ustedes y de lo que encontramos en internet, esta es como la lectura general que tenemos hoy en día, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_01]: Primero, lo más importante es como las unidades que ustedes tienen, que por lo que me contaron son más de 100 unidades, 100 vehículos, entre ellos pues tienen camiones y cajas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tengo el número de 120, no estoy 100% seguro si sí son 120, si son 120 en este momento iban a ser 130, pero están por ahí, no sé si tú sabes el valor exacto.
[SPEAKER_00]: Me parece que ya los 120 son con los 10 nuevos.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y los 120 creo que fue un número al aire.
[SPEAKER_00]: No estoy segura que sean 120 exactos, pero te lo confirmo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Listo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Igual simplemente es para tener una idea general.
[SPEAKER_01]: Digamos que son más de 100 vehículos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sí, más de 100.
[SPEAKER_01]: Los 10 vehículos que les acaban de entrar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Listo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Aquí estoy anotando también para hacer las correcciones.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bueno.
[SPEAKER_01]: vienen también no solamente estos 10 vehículos nuevos, sino que les entendí que van a tener un crecimiento también en la parte comercial o van a empezar a trabajar, a tener un influx de negocio importante.
[SPEAKER_01]: Digamos que también es una de las razones por las cuales quieren coger la información que tienen hoy en día y organizarla para que el día de mañana, hoy en día, digamos que tienen, entre comillas, y ya tú me corriges, tienen como un caos funcional.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sí, bastante, sí.
[SPEAKER_01]: Como que les funciona el negocio, pero no quieren que cuando lleguen nuevas unidades y llegue un nuevo trabajo y comience con un volumen más grande, que se desorganice todo y que ese caos pase de ser un caos funcional a un caos total.
[SPEAKER_01]: Esa es una de las razones por las cuales nos reunimos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y otro pilar muy importante es la información de los contenedores que ustedes quieren que manejan.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviamente hoy en día ustedes tienen mucha información que les llega de diferentes partes, entre ellas está el correo, el WhatsApp, lo que le responde las diferentes personas del equipo a tu madre, diciéndole información regada de lo que hay de los contenedores.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviamente toda esta información hay que unificarla y dejarla organizada.
[SPEAKER_01]: Digamos que esos son como los dos componentes grandes que identificamos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Primero es hacer un tracking y manejar la información organizada
[SPEAKER_01]: de los vehículos, y por segundo lado también está teniendo una información más organizada de los contenedores, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, cierto.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y ya como un eje transversal, pues que involucra las dos partes, lo que te mencionaba ahorita, pues como de la información desorganizada, como decía Héctor, que tenía como parchecitos de información, y es todo lo que manejan pues dentro del equipo, que hay muchos canales de WhatsApp, hay unas hojas sueltas de Excel que generan, yo creo que, pues por lo que le entendí a tu mamá, se generan
[SPEAKER_01]: casi que al día o al momento que alguien pide la información, la persona va y genera la hoja de Excel y la envía.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, pues hay como un dolor de consolidación de toda esa información y de seguimiento y más que todo del análisis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, hoy en día hacer un análisis de lo que realmente está pasando en la compañía es un poco difícil porque no hay un lugar, digamos que un sitio único donde esté toda la información actualizada, organizada y que alguien pueda entrar ahí y verlo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sí, correcto.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfecto.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, por ese lado lo que estamos viendo.
[SPEAKER_01]: De todo esto sacamos tres retos fundamentales y es primero poder entregar la información en tres minutos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, lo que tu mamá mencionaba de que ella necesita la información rápido y que a veces le pregunta a alguien y le pasa la pelota a otra persona y a otra y a otra.
[SPEAKER_01]: Digamos que lo ideal es que ustedes en menos de tres minutos tengan acceso a la información, lleguen a esta información de manera acertada y lo más actualizada posible y que esto sea en cualquier momento, en la noche, en la mañana, sin tener que hablar con alguien puntualmente, sin tener que escribirle a otra persona.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lo otro es manejar una información unificada de los 120 camiones donde se pueda controlar toda la información que les entrega Samsara, la información que les entrega los encargados de manejar a los conductores, cualquier reporte de accidente, cualquier reporte de daño, de reparación, etc.
[SPEAKER_01]: kilometrajes que entrega Samsara, recorridos, tiempos de encendido y todo esto.
[SPEAKER_01]: Digamos que es aprovechar todas las informaciones que ustedes tienen, consolidarlas en un solo sitio y que tengan unas hojas de vida claras y definidas de cada uno de los vehículos que ustedes manejan o que tienen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, muy bien.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y lo otro es consolidar toda la información de WhatsApp.
[SPEAKER_01]: La idea no es destruir los grupos de WhatsApp porque a pesar de que son un dolor de cabeza y...
[SPEAKER_01]: Y pueden ser muchos grupos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tú me dijiste que tú estás como en unos 7.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tu madre puede estar, entendí yo, que entre unos 15, 20 o más grupos de WhatsApp.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ya digamos que son formas de trabajar dentro de la compañía que ustedes tienen, que la intención de nosotros no es llegar y destruir y cambiar por completo, sino es, venga, si ustedes tienen esta infraestructura ya montada, construyamos algo que se organice y coja toda esa información y la ponga en un solo sitio.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces es seguir funcionando básicamente con lo que ustedes tienen.
[SPEAKER_01]: y centralizar los canales de comunicación, digamos que en un back office.
[SPEAKER_01]: No es lo que ustedes ven, sino que en la parte de atrás se coja toda esa información de los grupos de WhatsApp y se consolida en un solo punto.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, estas son las cinco grandes oportunidades que vemos.
[SPEAKER_01]: La primera es un asistente de WhatsApp que funciona de manera autónoma.
[SPEAKER_01]: No es una persona, es simplemente un asistente virtual que coge toda la información que llega por los diferentes grupos, la selecciona, la analiza y la organiza.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces cualquier foto que llegue, cualquier PDF, cualquier Excel, lo va a leer, va a entender qué es la información que viene y la va a montar en la hoja de Excel, por así decirlo, o en la hoja de Monday o en el programa que definamos que es el que queremos utilizar para que ustedes visualicen la información, va a montar toda esa información.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, ¿qué hace esto?
[SPEAKER_01]: Que tu madre no tiene que meterse o tú no tienes que meterte grupo por grupo a buscar dónde está la información, sino que pueden ir a sitios puntuales a encontrar la información directamente.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces esto va acompañado a sistemas de alerta, va acompañado a que si alguien escribió, venga el martes tenemos que llevar un camión a hacerle mantenimiento, entonces el sistema automáticamente genera una alerta y dice listo, el martes este camión lo agrega a la hoja de vida y un día antes, dos días antes, pues eso ya lo ajustamos a la preferencia que ustedes tengan.
[SPEAKER_01]: mandar un aviso, este camión tiene que llevarse ajuste, este camión X o Y cosa, y así con cualquier tipo de información, si es un contenedor o una caja, esta caja requiere mantenimiento, este contenedor llegó tal día, digamos que todo es recopilando la información de WhatsApp y metiéndola en un solo sitio o en los diferentes tres o cuatro Excel o plataformas que ustedes escojan que lo necesitan, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sí, muy bien.
[SPEAKER_01]: La primera gran oportunidad.
[SPEAKER_01]: La segunda es un filtro vivo de correos, lo mismo, es un filtro inteligente que pueda no solamente distribuir los correos a diferentes carpetas, que eso hoy en día funciona, si me llega un correo de Andrea, métalo a esta carpeta, si me llega un correo de Ricardo, métalo a esta otra carpeta, sino que vaya más allá, que coja los correos, los lea, vea que son acciones que toca referenciar y que toca saltar alertas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, llegó tal contenedor que mande un mensaje de WhatsApp, puede ser, o que mande un correo electrónico a la persona directa que tenga una alerta importante.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, es organizar toda la información que llega en esos correos y lo mismo, meterla en un Excel, organizarla, que quede asequible a cualquier persona, que no tenga que meterse a su cuenta de correo y filtrar entre 600 correos, sino que puede meterse un Excel y saber, venga, este correo llegó ayer y nos informó que este container ya quedó
[SPEAKER_01]: ya está listo, o ya lo bajaron del barco, ya lo montaron al camión, ya salió, lo que sea.
[SPEAKER_01]: Muy bien.
[SPEAKER_01]: La segunda gran oportunidad que vemos.
[SPEAKER_01]: La tercera es donde vamos a visualizar toda esta información que estamos sacando de WhatsApp y de los correos, un tablero maestro vivo de un Excel, o en Monday, o de nuevo, la plataforma que ustedes quieran.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ajá.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y que se ajuste a las necesidades que ustedes tienen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entendimos pues por lo que tu mamá y de pronto Héctor quieren es alejarse de los temas de suscripción, de es que estamos pagando XYZ plataforma y de pronto tener algo propio de ustedes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces es como empezar a que esto pase mil plataformas a...
[SPEAKER_01]: a un sitio donde ustedes puedan recopilar toda la información.
[SPEAKER_01]: No quiere decir que van a dejar de utilizar las otras plataformas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviamente hay información que está en Samsara o que está en Tracking, se me olvidó el nombre de esta aplicación en este momento.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tracking Premium.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exacto, Tracking Supreme, pero sí sabía que esa no era.
[SPEAKER_01]: De Tracking Premium y coger toda esa información, poder descargarla y meterla en un solo sitio.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces digamos que ese tablero maestro vivo es...
[SPEAKER_01]: la recopilación de todo lo que ustedes tienen y tenerlo en un sitio donde sea accionable, donde se pueda visualizar a tiempo real, donde se pueda tomar decisiones en base a lo que se está viendo en las diferentes partes de la compañía.
[SPEAKER_01]: En siguiente lugar tenemos el expediente de los camiones, que es la hoja de vida digital de los camiones, que es también agregar toda la información que puede llegar por WhatsApp,
[SPEAKER_01]: información que tienen, no sé, placas, modelos, toda la información que se pueda agregar de un camión, meterlo en una hoja de vida y entender, identificar si ese camión está rindiendo lo que debería rendir, si está haciendo los kilómetros que debería hacer o si en vez de hacerle tanto mantenimiento y sosteniéndolo tanto, es momento de hacer un cambio, invertir en otro camión o lo que sea.
[SPEAKER_01]: Digamos que nosotros lo que hacemos es agregar la información y presentárselas a ustedes, las decisiones ya directamente las toman ustedes, o si lo quieren llevar un paso más adelante, pues podríamos también entrar a analizarlo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y la última gran oportunidad que esto pues aborda a todo el equipo, obviamente tenemos que sentarnos persona con persona, ir viendo cuáles son las tareas que tú tienes, cuáles son las tareas que tiene Luis, las tareas que tiene tu mamá, y ver cómo podemos liberar con pequeñas acciones tiempo
[SPEAKER_01]: de las personas que son vitales para el equipo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, tú estás dedicándole mucho tiempo a hacer una transición de información de un Excel o un PDF o viceversa.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eso se puede automatizar, eso se puede hacer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y es que otras de esas pequeñas acciones que tengas tú, que tenga cualquier persona dentro del equipo, se pueden automatizar, se pueden reemplazar, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_01]: Pues se pueden llevar a que los haga un sistema.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, porque la persona que me pasa el Excel...
[SPEAKER_01]: ella arma ese excel por medio de información que le pasa a diferente gente por whatsapp entonces ella también se ahorraría un paso y como que siento que es una cadenita no claro entonces eso es muy importante queremos entender es la propuesta que les vamos a pasar esta conversación que estamos teniendo es como el entendimiento general que nosotros tenemos de la compañía obviamente como lo dijo Héctor y como lo dijo tu madre ir a conocer la bodega en los ángeles es muy importante
[SPEAKER_01]: a Guadalajara es muy importante entender el paso a paso de la información entonces ya no es de pronto eso que estamos haciendo que tú haces en el Excel de pronto no lo podemos evitar un paso más atrás y que esta persona no tenga que ni siquiera mandarte la información a ti o agregarla a un Excel sino que directamente con lo que le llega a ella se genere el reporte automáticamente entonces digamos que eso es muy importante esas sentadas esas conversaciones con cada persona del equipo para entender
[SPEAKER_01]: de dónde viene la información, cómo les llega y organizarla.
[SPEAKER_00]: Si quieres sigue, que creo que ibas a decir algo.
[SPEAKER_00]: Te iba a decir que estamos por agendar la ida a Los Ángeles, ya sea el miércoles o jueves de la siguiente semana.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfecto, excelente.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pero yo te avisaría a más tardar, hoy, ya sé que los horarios no son nada formales, pero igual hoy en la noche, como es mi mamá, no hay mucha formalidad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces mi mamá me confirma hoy tarde, pero yo te aviso si quieres mañana temprano o no sé,
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo te confirmo esta semana, bueno ya se acabó la semana, pero te confirmo hoy o mañana.
[SPEAKER_01]: Igual mis tiempos son cero formales, si tú le preguntas a Sofi, la única, la que se pone brava es Sofi, yo es que trabajo de 7 de la mañana, 9 de la noche, entonces yo no tengo ningún problema a la hora que me digan.
[SPEAKER_00]: Es que yo estoy acostumbrada a las 10 horas, porque como que hay tanta confianza en la oficina que no hay mucha formalidad, pero estamos trabajando en eso.
[SPEAKER_01]: No te preocupes, para mí es un whatsapp, no pasa nada.
[SPEAKER_01]: simplemente me dices yo si es miércoles puedo, si es jueves puedo si es viernes puedo, si es el día que sea puedo simplemente reservar ese día para ustedes claro, y ya sea que sigamos la siguiente semana, la próxima semana agendar para ir a, ah no, pero es que sabes que ya empieza el mundial y no sé si va a ser un caos allá, ir a Guadalajara sí es súper costoso claro que sí, si dan los tiempos para mí es perfecto porque Colombia juega en Guadalajara ah bueno pues mira, lo vamos a organizar
[SPEAKER_01]: en un ratito voy a ver a mi mamá entonces lo organizamos y lo platicamos y te aviso voy a cerrar la puerta porque están aspirando y me molesta sí listo ya, perdona ya estaba ahí, no sé si tú lo escuchabas pero yo sí lo sentía aquí ah no
[SPEAKER_01]: Bueno, entonces, cuando quieran.
[SPEAKER_01]: Por mí, simplemente me dicen, lo agendamos, pasan lo que sea la información que necesiten, o no sé si de pronto habrán sitios que toca presentar documentación, yo tengo todo el día, y simplemente me dicen qué hay que comprar, qué hay que hacer, y lo hacemos.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, lo de Los Ángeles sería ida y vuelta, entonces, nos iríamos juntos, y lo de Guadalajara, tú no te preocuparías por los viáticos, sería por nuestra parte.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y, este...
[SPEAKER_00]: Y allá ya veríamos cuántos días nos quedamos, yo creo que unas dos noches, dependiendo, porque sí, casi siempre llegamos a la mitad del día, depende del vuelo, entonces como que ya no se aprovecha mucho.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, no se puede aprovechar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces, yo me organizo y ya te comento.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfecto.
[SPEAKER_01]: Igual lo que te digo, esto es de tiempo, esto no es como que con una idea a Guadalajara vamos a resolver, no, pues eso es de ir.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sí, claro, pero para que veas.
[SPEAKER_01]: De sentarme, de conversar, de analizar y todo eso.
[SPEAKER_01]: Aquí, yo creo que esto es un punto muy importante para Héctor y pues para todos, para la tranquilidad del equipo, es que entiendan que nosotros no buscamos reemplazar a nadie ni decir, no, es que usted no va a necesitar a esta persona o esta persona ya va a salir del equipo porque es que lo vamos a automatizar.
[SPEAKER_01]: La idea no es esa, la idea es simplemente que las tareas que tú de pronto perdías porque para ti era un tiempo frustrante de dos o tres horas pasando un Excel, que eso no es...
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces es un trabajo casi que de un robotcito que lo debería hacer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Es que esas tareas van a desaparecer en la medida de lo posible, esas tareas van a desaparecer y lo que les va a brindar a ustedes es tiempo de tomar decisiones, de analizar la información, de ver realmente qué se puede hacer para que la compañía funcione mejor, funcione más rápido, conseguir más clientes, vender más.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces digamos que eso es lo importante que entiendan
[SPEAKER_01]: todos dentro de la compañía, es que nosotros no les vamos a decir, es que ustedes tienen que echar, tienen que salir de eso.
[SPEAKER_01]: Digamos que nuestra consultoría es más en optimización de información, en optimización de procesos, en velocidad y presentación de la información, más que, no, es que usted tiene que salir de cinco personas porque va a recortar gastos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nosotros no nos metemos en eso y no es lo que queremos hacer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces eso también es muy claro que todos lo tengamos presente.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, todo esto, lo que te decía, es un proceso, esto no es que mañana vamos a empezar a implementar y que mañana vamos a... Obviamente, y entendí, ya pues tú me corregirás, a Héctor le gustan de pronto las cosas que sean implementables muy rápido, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_01]: Que sea, venga, yo quiero que esto funcione, no me diga que esto sea demorar un año, sea demorar seis meses, no, yo quiero empezar a ver resultados casi que rápido.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, digamos que hay formas de llevarlo a que los ejercicios funcionen de forma paralela,
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviamente, en un principio no van a ser perfectos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Esto no es una implementación que no funciona.
[SPEAKER_01]: Esto es que lo vamos a ir construyendo porque son herramientas construidas para ustedes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y es, primero tenemos que ver qué llega a cada grupo, qué es la información que pasa, entender bien cuáles son las etapas que ustedes como equipo tienen para que la solución que implementemos funcione a la medida de ustedes.
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Cierto?
[SPEAKER_01]: Muy bien.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lo que les pasó con...
[SPEAKER_01]: Tracking Premium.
[SPEAKER_01]: Que un día tenían algo acostumbrado y llegó otro cliente y esas personas movieron y nos cambió.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, la idea es que lo que construyamos sea para ustedes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, eso sí requiere un poquito de paciencia.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lo que no quiere decir es que en dos años van a tener ustedes el no.
[SPEAKER_01]: La idea es reunirnos, empezar a ver y desde la primera reunión que yo tenga contigo, con tu mamá, con el que sea, empezar a, digamos que, a diseñar y a llevar un proceso paralelo de continuo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Empezamos con un entendimiento de qué es lo que hay que hacer
[SPEAKER_01]: sin frenar operaciones, no queremos que ustedes paren de funcionar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Después del entendimiento ya diseñamos, ese diseño se lo compartimos ustedes, digamos que cada etapa es en equipo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, el entendimiento es conjunto, les hacemos preguntas, venga, confirmamos, esto sí es así, esto no es así, esto por qué es así.
[SPEAKER_01]: Después el diseño es, vea, esta es la propuesta que nosotros tenemos, ¿les sirve, no les sirve?
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Qué les gustaría cambiar?
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Qué les gustaría agregar?
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Qué no necesitan?
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Qué sí es útil, qué no?
[SPEAKER_01]: La validación es eso, es la comprobación ya,
[SPEAKER_01]: De ese diseño, digamos que el diseño no es que nosotros hacemos todo en un cuadrito, pues lo pintamos, sino que lo vamos haciendo y dibujando, pues, y lo validamos es que las cosas sí estén funcionando.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ya la construcción sí es implementar la solución de una manera un poco más sólida, que sea más robusta, y empiezan las pruebas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces las pruebas ya sí es, venga, esto sí está funcionando, esto sí no está haciendo, no queremos decirle a tu mamá, no, es que ya WhatsApp va, tú te tienes que desentender de WhatsApp.
[SPEAKER_01]: La idea es que se vayan haciendo el trabajo en conjunto.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, entonces el asistente de WhatsApp sí está funcionando muy bien, me está haciendo las tareas más rápidas, me está sacando la información de manera correcta.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces yo de pronto puedo empezar a soltar por este lado y dejar que el asistente haga eso.
[SPEAKER_01]: No es que tú pares inmediatamente de hacer el copy-paste del Excel al PDF, es que vamos probando por los dos lados y ya en un momento que tú digas, venga, es que esto sí está funcionando muy bien, entonces yo ya tengo que revisar y no tengo qué hacer.
[SPEAKER_01]: y ya, hasta llegar al punto que el día de mañana, no, es que esto ya va solo, casi que lo podemos mandar y simplemente una supervisión rápida porque se puede llegar a ese punto.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y una vez que terminemos las pruebas, viene un proceso de acompañamiento en el cual estamos con ustedes, capacitación, vamos viendo que se esté funcionando, la idea no es cambiar los procesos de trabajo, la idea no es llegar y poner una nueva metodología,
[SPEAKER_01]: porque ustedes más que nadie conocen cómo funciona el negocio, cuáles son las tareas del día a día, pero si obviamente cualquier solución que implementemos puede ser más útil o menos útil dependiendo del uso que ustedes le den, como cualquier programa en el mundo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces hay personas que utilizan Excel para simplemente ver la información y casi que tienen la calculadora al lado.
[SPEAKER_01]: Esa es una forma de trabajar con Excel, no es la forma óptima.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviamente, si uno ya pone las fórmulas dentro de las casillas de Excel, pues funciona mejor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Digamos que nuestra herramienta se va a acoplar más al trabajo de ustedes, pero igual también se puede optimizar diciendo, venga, utilicemos todos la misma plantilla.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cuando escriban un mensaje, escriban de qué es el mensaje.
[SPEAKER_01]: No solamente manden la foto por mandarla, sino que digan, esta foto es de, oye, como pequeñas soluciones que tampoco les va a cambiar los hábitos de trabajo, pero que sí va a hacer que la herramienta funcione mucho mejor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Muy bien.
[SPEAKER_01]: ¿Listo?
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces ya pues los próximos pasos obviamente sería, esta presentación que te estoy haciendo yo hoy en día es ya formalizarlo un poco más después de escuchar tus comentarios, llevarla a una presentación con tu mamá, con Héctor, obviamente primero pues filtrar todo lo que tú me digas, tus opiniones, los comentarios para que quede un poquito más organizado y presentarles a ellos esto que te estoy presentando a ti de una forma digamos que un poco más,
[SPEAKER_01]: No más formal, porque no quiero que esto no sea formal, pero sí más organizada, más puntual, un poquito más de detalle, no tan rápido, sino ya resolviendo preguntas que de pronto ellos puedan tener y todo eso, ¿cierto?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sí, cierto.
[SPEAKER_01]: No sé si quieras de pronto hacerlo en la bodega primero o lo de la bodega después.
[SPEAKER_01]: Por mi parte, digamos que podría ser ambas cosas.
[SPEAKER_01]: Podría ser, primero les presentamos nosotros la idea del proyecto, con eso ya dicen, listo, perfecto, vale la pena que hagamos la visita en la bodega, o quieres, no, venga, vamos a la visita en la bodega, porque es que ahí también hay muchas cosas que se pueden después volver a revisar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo digo que sí, que sí vayamos a la bodega, porque ahí sí te van a abrir muchos ojos, o sea, sí es, yo creo que sí es indispensable.
[SPEAKER_01]: Listo, perfecto.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, hacemos primero bodega,
[SPEAKER_01]: y después lleva una información que también me parece bien porque en esa segunda reunión vamos a tener mucha más información y va a ser digamos que una solución mucho más aterrizada no algo como tan general que tenemos en este momento sí, sí, sí, claro entonces listo, visitamos bodega después nos reunimos, les presentamos ese primer análisis la primera propuesta, ya les decimos vea, estas son las soluciones que queremos implementar más o menos estos son los precios por los cuales estamos pues como creemos que va a costar realizar todo esto
[SPEAKER_01]: lo que le dije a tu mamá, nosotros no vamos a cobrar por hora, cobramos es por implementaciones, es verdad, esto va a costar tanto, va a funcionar de esta y de esta manera, y ya queda funcionando.
[SPEAKER_01]: Si de pronto es una solución que requiere que nosotros tengamos una capacidad computacional por nuestro lado, pues ahí sí hay que tener una suscripción, porque obviamente nosotros estamos haciendo un gasto energético, de consumo de energía artificial, todo eso, pero eso ya después lo organizamos.
[SPEAKER_01]: La idea es que ustedes ya escojan las soluciones que quieren implementar y que nos vayamos por esas soluciones.
[SPEAKER_00]: Muy bien.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, nada, ya esto es como la presentación que te tenía para ti.
[SPEAKER_01]: No sé si tienes comentarios, dudas, si me suenan las ideas, si me suenan las soluciones, por qué no investigan esto, cualquier cosa que tú digas es súper beneficiosa para nosotros en este momento, teniendo en cuenta que vamos a sacar mucha más información con las visitas.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, yo creo que, no, la verdad me pareció excelente todo, y más porque sé que es algo que como vamos a crecer mucho ahorita, o sea, si no lo implementamos ahorita, la verdad creo que sí sería algo catastrófico para Strix, porque vamos a crecer como sin una estructura muy clara, pues.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y nada más me quedo con que sí quisiera que sí fuéramos a la bodega pronto, porque...
[SPEAKER_00]: de ahí siento que van a salir muchas más basuritas, o sea, como que vas a decir, uy, ¿sabes qué?
[SPEAKER_00]: O sea, las cajas, creo que por aquí nos podemos ir, porque yo viendo aquí, pues la caja, llegan varias a tal hora, o sea, como que siento que sí, sí van a salir más cosas.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pero allá afuera...
[SPEAKER_00]: Excelente, muy bien.
[SPEAKER_01]: Buenísimo, mil gracias.
[SPEAKER_01]: Igual ya en las visitas iremos conversando más.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sí, claro.
[SPEAKER_01]: La propuesta, mejor dicho, que sí es mejor esperar porque es tener un... Y lo que te digo, así hagamos la visita, eso no es de ir una vez a Los Ángeles, eso es de ir, meterse a Los Ángeles varias veces, entender bien el proceso.
[SPEAKER_01]: Intentar hablar con esta persona que es medio complicada.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don Beto, creo que se llama.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, no, es la verdad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Es muy complicado, muy grosero, muy prepotente.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y por ejemplo, Raúl también dice, es que no entiendo, porque como Héctor dijo, que tiene muchos virus, ¿no?
[SPEAKER_00]: O sea, muchos así.
[SPEAKER_00]: Y Raúl dice, porque Raúl un tiempo estuvo apoyándonos con choferes y me dice que no podía entender, o sea, cómo tenía gente que...
[SPEAKER_00]: que se portaba de esa manera y que Héctor no tenía autoridad, y si lo ves a él, es una persona, un hombre, le tienes muchísimo respeto, es un señorón, pero Raúl no lo puede entender, yo tampoco, pero como él dice, a veces pasa, tienes que tener a un monstruo para que te haya orden, así un capataz.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yo creo que también es de parte lealtad de Héctor, por lo que vi es una persona que quiere mucho su equipo,
[SPEAKER_01]: que no respeta, que no está dispuesto a votar gente porque alguien le dijo, sino que él tiene que ver.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y de pronto hay soluciones que ya digamos que se sale un poquito más, y te lo digo yo pues como site, digamos que no oficialmente, que de pronto se pueden implementar, que pues no sé la facilidad, obviamente yendo a bodega uno va a ver cuál es la facilidad, pero opciones para que las personas hagan un...
[SPEAKER_01]: una reserva online a la hora que quieren recoger sus paquetes y con eso no tienen que ver a esta persona, sino que justo en esos slots de tiempo asignados hay otra persona que se encarga de entregar los paquetes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, no, al contrario, él se encarga de recibir mercancía.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_00]: Entonces el cliente llega, no, no, se los entrega en Guadalajara.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, bien.
[SPEAKER_00]: O sea, él se, pero él llega a los clientes a dejar mercancía.
[SPEAKER_00]: o clientes se comunican con él para precios, porque hay clientes que llegan así, porque nos vieron la dirección, llegan y, ay, ¿cuánto cuesta llevarme esto a México?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, pero se vuelven locos, hay clientes que no lo conocen, pero hay clientes que sí, entonces, pues, dicen, pues, bueno, o sea, el servicio está tan bueno que, pues, está feo, pues, te voy a enseñar, te voy a mandar ahorita fotos de nuestras reviews de Facebook que están para llorar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y solo son de él, pues.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hay otra cosa que es que yo creo que no lo tenemos como un
[SPEAKER_01]: puesto en esta presentación o no lo comenté, porque digamos que obviamente dentro de la propuesta van a haber más soluciones o implementaciones que van por impacto.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, digamos que el impacto crítico en este momento es ustedes, digamos, que organizar un poquito más de información.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hay otro impacto, que Luis lo mencionó, es que nosotros tenemos que vender más nuestra marca, que nos conozcan más, llegar a más clientes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces, también hay una parte que es más
[SPEAKER_01]: Digamos que marketing, por decirlo entre comillas, que es abrir un LinkedIn profesional, que es tener una página de Instagram con más actividad, con buscar más crecimiento.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviamente hay compañías que se venden por Instagram, hay compañías que no se venden por Instagram.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, pero sería bueno también.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pero exacto, siempre, y más hoy en día la gente siempre busca es, venga, es que me recomendaron esta, uy, en LinkedIn se ve muy buena, voy a ver también en Instagram a ver si es real, si existe, si tiene una persona que se comprometa.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces también hay otras alternativas que son más de imagen que se pueden implementar, obviamente con diferentes capacidades de alcance.
[SPEAKER_01]: No somos una compañía de marketing, pero podemos generar herramientas que a ustedes les faciliten manejar las redes sociales o podemos generar que, venga, es que quiero que publique todos los días a tal hora.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces generamos la herramienta que haga eso.
[SPEAKER_01]: y que saque el contenido, entonces digamos que ustedes tienen que despreocupar que eso también va dentro de la gran propuesta pero no es algo vital que veamos en este momento, simplemente te digo Sí, pero yo creo que ya más adelante sí sería sería bueno platicarlo para que lo tengas presente entonces pues nada André, eso era no sé si tienes ahí de pronto un insight de temas de presupuesto o esto después en consultorías que hayan solicitado antes o nunca han solicitado consultorías No, la verdad no
[SPEAKER_00]: Yo pienso que tú manda tus precios y no te preocupes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ya lo checamos nosotros y si vemos que está un poco fuera, pues te lo platicamos y nos ponemos de acuerdo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exacto, eso es conversado.
[SPEAKER_01]: Y podemos empezar con una solución y después ver cómo funciona y irnos con otras y ahí vamos como trabajando.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces nada, no te quito más tiempo.
[SPEAKER_01]: De nuevo te agradezco por abrir las puertas, por esta reunión.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lo que necesites por parte mío también, venga, es que se me ocurrió esto, mira esto, estoy pendiente de cualquier cosa, yo pues lo que te digo WhatsApp para mí simplemente es en cualquier momento me puedes escribir y yo voy a responder.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pues muchísimas gracias y me queda pendiente nada más confirmarte las fechas de a ver cuándo nos vamos.
[SPEAKER_01]: Excelente, mil gracias Andrés.
[SPEAKER_01]: Entonces la próxima semana ya sabemos que vamos para Los Ángeles, simplemente es confirmar fechas y ver es cuándo podríamos ir a Guadalajara.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sí, claro que sí.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfecto, que sea muy bien.
[SPEAKER_01]: Saludos por allá.
[SPEAKER_01]: Igual, estoy pendiente.